you don't ever miss running wild than
just breaking all the rules
hey Deb Karen you'd better think twice
before you yawn on set put that phone
away Sophia Carson boo-boos Stewart
Disney will pick out all your clothes
and Sarah Jeffery if you think you can
just book any gig without running it by
Disney think again this is just a taste
of the strict rules for the cast of
descendants three here are 10 of these
strictest rules the cast of descendants
three must follow you'll have a hard
time believing number one watch until
the end to find out why no yawning all
that dancing acting and singing can be
super tiring but don't let descendants
director Kenny Ortega catch you yawning
on set if he caught any of his cast
members mid yawn he made them pay him a
dollar
that's right it actually cost the actors
money when they yawned but don't worry
after production wraps he always donates
all the proceeds to the make-a-wish
Foundation so he turns those expensive
yawns into a good cause for other kids
absolutely no bullying director Kenny
Ortega has a very strict rule against
bullying or ridiculing anybody on set
back on the set of high school musical
some of the background actors were
picking on a girl for showing up on set
in the same clothes for three days in a
row
Kenny notice the laughter and found out
the girl's story turns out she was being
moved to her third foster home so I
called the cast over and I sat down with
them
and had a strict conversation with them
ever since then he will not tolerate any
bullying on set no other gigs when
you're working for Disney it's best to
clear your schedule otherwise you could
be written out of a movie that's what
happened with Sarah Jeffery who plays
the role of Audrey in the first
Descendants film as well as the third
but she did not make an appearance in
d2r do went off to a spa vacation with
flora fauna and Merryweather that's
because she was working on other
projects after the first descendants
Jeffrey starred in NBC's shades of blue
Fox's wayward Pines and the CW's charmed
you don't have to be alone anymore
thankfully she cleared her calendar for
d3 no smoking this role isn't just for
the cast of descendants it's for all
Disney stars across the board in fact
the characters are forbidden to smoke in
any Disney or Disney related project
including Lucasfilm pics
and marvel it's kind of ironic since
Walt Disney was known for doing the
exact opposite but times have changed it
doesn't vibe with Disney's squeaky-clean
image so tobacco is a no no no posting
without permission this is a pretty
common rule among movie and TV studios
nowadays there are strict rules about
what the cast of Disney descendants are
allowed to share on social media
regarding the movies in a time of
spoilers leaked videos is just total TMI
this role actually makes sense
descendants fans are constantly on the
hunt for insider secrets about these
Disney Channel films so the Stars have
to be super careful to not reveal too
much too soon
I can't give away all of the secrets
princess etiquette training the
etiquette classes Disney forces their
stars to take just aren't for princesses
there's a villain kids too everybody
wants me to be this lady of the court
and have no idea how to keep up the act
apparently all Disney stars must get
formal training on how to behave in real
life as well as on social media the idea
is to help the actors avoid too many
pitfalls of Fame since Disney child
stars live somewhat sheltered lives it
makes sense that Disney would want to
educate them on what to avoid the studio
prefers to call these classes guidance
sessions on life skills
when in doubt play them whenever a cast
member of descendants is asked a tough
interview question they're taught one
response play dumb maybe there's no
villains maybe we're the villains
actually technically we are the villains
whenever a reporter asks a difficult
question they must remain sweet and
swiftly change the subject
yeah I just can't wait for people to see
it I can't say too much they're told
what to wear Disney likes to maintain
control over almost every aspect of
their star's lives one prime example of
this is with their clothing Disney
actually picks out what the actors wear
on and off set this is done to portray a
certain image to represent Disney so the
clothes that Dov Boo Boo's Sofia and the
rest of the cast wore at Disney's recent
fan fest were most likely selected for
them by the studio image is
super-important to Disney I mean shoes
morality clause since Disney's main
viewership is children and preteens it's
important for them to maintain a
family-friendly vibe that means steering
clear of anything controversial or
risque that's why Disney makes The
Descendants star signed contracts with
the morality clause this clause states
that the Disney will drop their actors
like a hot potato if they get involved
in any immoral embarrassing or
controversial shenanigans they just
can't have the talent tarnishing the
studio's golden reputation and we're all
done girls now dating Disney just might
have something to do with dub Cameron
and Thomas Doherty dating each other for
many years Disney has encouraged stars
to only date one another this isn't the
first time we've seen Disney stars fall
in love look at Britney Spears and
Justin Timberlake and Nick Jonas and
Selena Gomez that makes us wonder who
else from the cast of descendants three
will start dating so which actors from
d3 would you love to see together tell
us in the comments for more videos about
the cast of descendants hit that
subscribe button and be sure to give
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching see you later
[Music]